تعلن روسيا اعتراضها على استمرار
الاتفاقيه التي تسمح بتصدير الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود لكنها تترك الباب مفتوحا
امام استئناف العمل بها قال المتحدث باسم
الكرملين انه بمجرد تنفيذ الجزء المتعلق
بروسيا من الاتفاقيه ستعود اليها فورا
الرئيس التركي الذي اثمرت وساطته
الاتفاقيه بدا متفائلا ايضا وقال انه رغم
اعلان توقف الاتفاقيه فان الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين يريد الاستمرار فيها بدا العمل
باتفاقيه الحبوب في يوليو السنه الماضيه
بواسطه تركيه ورعايه امميه تؤمن الاتفاق
السفن التي تنقل الحبوب في البحر الاسود
عبر مضيق البوسفور في اتجاه مناطق مختلفه
من العالم تقدم روسيا ضمانات امنيه يسمح
من خلالها اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي بفتح
ممر بحري انساني ويضمن سلامه الملاحه
البحريه وهي الضمانات التي اعلنت روسيا
سحبها الان في اسطنبول اقيم مركز للمراقبه
لتفتيش السفن من عدم استغلالها لنقل
الاسلحه تشارك فيه روسيا واوكرانيا وتركيا
والامم المتحده لماذا هذه الاتفاقيه مهمه
تنتج روسيا واوكرانيا نحو ثلث ما يحتاج
اليه العالم من الحبوب ولذلك شهدت اسعارها
بعد اندلاع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ارتطاعا صاروخيا عاد تطبيق الاتفاقيه بعد
التوازن الى السوق العالميه وتمكنت
اوكرانيا خلال سنه تقريبا من تصدير نحو 33
مليون طن من الحبوب لكن روسيا انسحبت منها
ثلاث مرات في السابق قبل ان تعود اليها في
كل مره بعد وقت قصير تقول موسكو ان البنود
المتعلقه بتصدير حبوبها واسمنتها لا تحترم
وتضيف ان اغلب حبوب اوكرانيا توجه الى
الدول الغنيه ولا تستفيد منها الدول
الفقيره لا تخضع المواد الغذائيه الروسيه
للعقوبات الغربيه لكن شركات النقل
والتامين تتردد في نقل هذه المواد خوفا من
التي تفرضها العقوبات على التحويلات
الماليه ومع ذلك تمكنت روسيا حسب اداره
التقريرات الفلاحيه الامريكيه من تصدير 45
مليون وخمسمائه الف طن من الحبوب في عام
2022 وتتوقع ان تصدر اكثر هذه السنه الان
يقول الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده مستعده لتصدير الحبوب حتى دون
مشاركه روسيا اذا تلقت ضمانات من الشركاء
لكن الجميع يامل عوده روسيه سريعه الى
الاتفاقيه لان اسعار القمح في سوق شيكاغو
ارتفعت بنسبه 3% مباشره بعد اعلان توقف
العمل بالاتفاقيه